so
i'm gonna make a really weird looking
move knight
knight h4
in order to attempt to distract the
knight away from g6
[Music]
white with a 1718
all right
e4 c5 well you all know what i'm doing
smith mora
accepted let's see if well obviously
yeah accept it accept it
yes
okay so we go knight f3
and e6 which is
a pretty popular system one of the
better systems that black has
and those of you who have uh watched the
previous speedruns and seen the mora
games uh know what the theoretical move
here is which is in my opinion very
counter-intuitive i feel like your your
brain won't really tell you to play like
this but this move has some very deep
ideas behind it that is to develop the
bishop to c4 now the reason you might
not play it is because the bishop is
just biting on granite to use my
favorite expression but there are many
cases where you suck a knight on d5 the
pawn on e6 disappears and then the
bishop opens up and there's other
reasons you would put it on c4 i'll get
into this later 97 is
not the move as far as i know
97 is not the move as far as i know
um but there is no direct way to punish
i mean there's a couple of tempting
moves that we could play the d6 square
of course is what we ultimately want to
try to exploit
so we can play bishop out to f4 one idea
to try to put it on d6
uh we can play knight b5
but if we played ip5 black could go d5
or black could go knight e7 to g6 and
we're not in time to put our knight on
d6 i mean we can put our knight 26 but
it'll be captured
so in such situations
i feel like a lot of people spend a lot
of time looking for something insane but
let's practice just being
straightforward and castling let's just
put this decision off knight g6
all right
so um
now i think it might be a good
opportunity to test out you know i call
this the mark esterman move so as i
mentioned the idea of putting the bishop
on c4 i'm sure castles is not the best
move by the way but still i want to show
you that playing simple chess
can still be good
i think that in these positions just
throwing the knight onto d5 could be a
pretty interesting idea probably not
objectively sound but
let's see what happens
let's see what happens if we just throw
our knight onto d5
the reason i don't think this is very
good is because is not because of oh i
think he needs a mistake oh i don't
think our opponent knows what's waiting
for him
uh oh
now maybe this is unsound i don't know
but i want to have some fun
i want to have some fun
[Music]
now this is not entirely a preposterous
sacrifice and you shouldn't if you're
thinking to yourself the sacrifice is
insane i would never play like this then
you're doing something wrong because
you should understand sort of
intuitively why the sacrifice actually
has a chance of working which is that
black is completely underdeveloped
completely undeveloped and neither
bishop is is developed so black isn't
close to castling and the other thing is
that the e file being wide open means
that a check on e1 followed by d6 i mean
white's got a wealth of of
ideas that that could just end the game
all right so 95
first important thing to understand is
that
when you're in the gambit mindset to
borrow a phrase used in chat
you have to realize that you're not
always going to respond to a threat by
uh defending against it
straightforwardly so here for instance
you wouldn't automatically move the
bishop
i think we will make a bishop move but
not because we have to move the bishop
we could also give a check on e1 but
then black plays bishop e7 and then if
we play d6 black will capture the knight
on c4 and
at best will only win back one of the
pieces
now i should want to move the bishop
where should we move it well
the move d7 d6 is one way the black can
try to consolidate so let's go bishop b5
in order to prevent d6 to keep this
bishop undeveloped and to make it harder
for black
to untangle that's very important when
you sacrifice a knight like this
a6
there's some interesting ideas here
so bishop a4 he wants b5
yeah not so simple here to find a good
move
okay let's go rookie one check
all right let's run the check first
now let's go d6 actually wait a second
ah no no i know what we're gonna oh yeah
yeah let's go d6 let's go d6 we have to
otherwise black castle he takes
and now i need a second to think because
if we take on e7 then he uses the pawn
as an umbrella but we don't need to rush
with d take c7
we don't need to rush with d take c7
what we can try to do is distract this
knight from g6 so that we can then take
on e7 with the rook and i think that
breathes
new life into the attack
so
i'm gonna make a really weird looking
move knight
knight h4
in order to attempt to distract the
knight away from g6 now again i i played
very unsoundly here
this is not how i like to play in the
speed run
but
i don't know i i feel like
i want to play a couple of tactical
games at this level and sort of see how
people defend and see how how this style
works
why not bishop g5 well bishop g5 black
just has f7 f6
okay knight c6 great our opponent is
playing great
now i actually think that taking on e7
though
you know knight c6 is a phenomenal move
if we take on e7 unfortunately black can
just take
this ain't good ladies and gentlemen
this is really really not good we're out
of ideas
knight f5 castles amazingly okay let's
take
let's take we have to win at least one
of the pieces back
yeah maybe bishop g5
but then f6
okay well um let's try it
let's give it a shot
i haven't well no everything everything
just doesn't work here it's crazy
nothing seems to
seems to quite do the trick
i have an idea
that that doesn't work either
this might just be a loss
the way our opponent is defending
when h5 castles i mean it's like every
move there is a simple refutation
did you try this move
i'm not used to somebody defending i
mean i wasn't expecting our opponent to
defend this wall honestly
okay that gives us some life that gives
us a little bit of life
but not much oh wait no no no no we have
a really oh we might be winning
we have a swindle move so 96 check
obviously
okay so i jinxed the narrative jinx
strikes again i just need to compliment
people more knight d6 second after king
f8
it's not queen f3
it's not queen f3 that's the muppet the
most popular wrong answer because of
knight g6 to f4
blocking
the queen's check and then you might say
well why not g3 in that position
remember we are down two pieces just
winning one of them back is not enough
we need a lot more than that
so the way you want to think about it is
thinking in terms of squares
what is the potential mating square well
the potential mating square is f7
is f3 the only pathway no there is the
alternate pathway queen b3 and that move
is so much stronger because black
literally cannot put anything in front
of the the queen
the black's only move is to play queen
e8 which by the way is not an easy win
for white at all
but is definitely winning
yeah he 100 legit obviously and i just
gave him a lot of pieces he took them
and he found a couple of nice
consolidating moves
yep there's no defense i mean look at
this
we're down two pieces
but black doesn't have enough activity
to muster up a defense against queen f7
that doesn't involve giving up the queen
yeah this is like gm luck right here i
was totally out of ideas had our
opponent castled we would have been i'm
not saying we would have lost i think
there's a high chance that i would have
swindled him but it was just literally
down a piece for no comp
we definitely need to check with an
engine because knight g7 i know is wrong
i know black has to play a6 but i'm just
not sure exactly what it is that white's
supposed to do here
and castling was just sort of a cop out
queen e8 okay so we can throw in a check
on f3
uh but then there's knight f4
so that's unnecessary
we should just take the queen
and we have basically two approaches i
think to winning this the first is the
direct approach of attacking down the
e-file and we can just double rooks on
the e-file but
i don't see a reason for us not to take
a couple of pawns while we have the
opportunity while black is still
undeveloped we should we should build up
some insurance by taking the pawns
the other thing we could consider here
yeah and i think we should take the
other one as well
and now we have a little bit more
material we can
we can breathe
i have five and that's a blunder and
this i've talked about this many times
when one blunder happens
you know often people are
discombobulated and there's a certain
level and experience level at which you
stop being quite as discombobulated uh
after blunders but that we haven't
reached that point yet and black resigns
wow what a game
what a what a crazy game i apologize for
those
to you guys watching on youtube this was
just not not not good quality chess by
me
and i knew it wasn't but i i just wasn't
expecting us to run out of ideas so
quickly
if i'm honest i miss knight a5 like i
saw that this move existed
but i didn't i underestimated it
tremendously
and i only thought that i only
considered knight c e5
and here i had a really cool idea
so here i had a really cool idea after
95.95
so you guys probably see them with
rookie one and you probably also see
that after d6 f4 white wins back the
night and that's
possible but this isn't amazing because
black can go bishop e7
let's say f takes e5 d takes e5 rook
takes c5 and black castles and at the
end of the day material is equal and
white's king is a little bit flimsy here
so
this isn't a very impressive line for
white who can spot an alternative to
rookie one
in in in the spirit that's more in the
spirit of the position
yeah now i'm not sure whether this is
good or not but the move i was planning
on was d6
cutting off the bishop and obviously if
knight takes c4 rookie one check is
devastating bishop e7 rookie seven
i'm sure there's a win here for white
somewhere
i mean bishop g5 looks really good
for starters creating an x-ray against
the queen discovered that he has mate
it's crushing
you don't want to go queen d5 here this
is a blunder
who can tell me why
okay this is a weird game
knight takes d6
and how do you see a move like this well
i'm pretty obsessed with the notion of
contact between pieces
i've talked a lot about undefended
pieces on the speedo a thing i haven't
talked about as much
is
any situation in which two pieces are
making contact right queen is making
contact with the rook
and you might ignore that because the
rook is defended by a pawn but
you know pawns can be captured
and uh these situations
are um
are incredibly incredibly dangerous and
i have obviously a lot of examples of
that
why not take with the ponder when
because this doesn't win the queen
the queen has squares along this
diagonal the pawn serves as an umbrella
for the black king
shielding it from everything that can
happen to it
okay
so
let's analyze with an engine
all right so knight g7
yeah so apparently the move is
this is an interesting line i mean the
engine doesn't seem to think that it's
that great for white knight b5
oh this is cool so one move that i was
afraid of is d5
and here
it's important there's a very tempting
idea ed5 ed5 bishop d5
um
but this is with the idea knight t5
queen d5 but this is not good because of
this intermediate check bishop before
check
this is just crappy for white
so the idea is completely different
after d5
you suddenly play bishop f4 i completely
missed this move
just threatening knight c7 and knight c7
can barely be stopped but wow what a
complicated line knight g6
check king e7
i mean the depth is very low here i feel
like this has to be good for white
somehow
but this needs to be analyzed with a
with a serious stock fish not with a
depth you know depth 20 stock fish
you can see how complicated the smith
mora is
so d5 is one move knight g6 is another
move
and here i was not impressed by this
i was not impressed by this because
black simply has queen e7
and uh
what has white gained from putting
something on d6
right i don't really see it the queen
trade is is on tap and black is up upon
so the queen trade favors him
not uh not convincing at all so this has
to be looked at more deeply
wow
oh so the engine actually likes castling
here but again i wouldn't really trust
the engine at anything other than depth
like 40 here
no it does go past f20 it's just pretty
slow
okay so castles
knight g6
and obviously knight d5 is going to be
hated by the engine
or not no it's actually not so bad
and i wonder what the eval is here wow
it's actually not bad at all
ed5 ed5 so knight knight a5 is not the
well it is the best according to the
engine
and now
apparently we made a mistake
so the engine line here is rookie one
check bishop oh
d6
knight c4de
and i stopped calculating here
and i figured that
black is fine because the king is
totally sheltered but apparently
concretely black is not fine b3
okay so you're attacking the knight
let's say the knight moves away
oh so this is interesting even though
the pawn is here the king is not safe
because you play knight d4 and you're
threatening knight b5 knight d6 with
checkmate
the fact that the king is out of squares
is very important here and the king can
never castle as long as you keep this
pawn alive
so i kind of underestimated white's
long-term attacking chances here that's
kind of interesting
wow just cold-bloodedly knight d4 on
this pawn is it will be there forever
and if black ever captures it i mean
this is completely winning bishop a3 and
you're just
slicing
slicing through the position
yeah very instructive so and if knight
takes e7 lose pieces drop off there's an
undefended knight on c4 and a pawn on g7
and you can attack both of them with
queen d4
and black has no choice but to give up
the knight on c4 castles queen c4
and black is still fine black is up a
pawn but
you know it's probably about equal
because white's got control of the
square in front of the pawn
huh very cool
so we played bishop b5 mistake
um a6 correct
now i kind of panicked check yeah check
is exacerbates the issue bishop
b7 and now it's just bad the the the the
compensation has evaporated d6ab knight
h4
knight h4 is the top move so i found the
best chance
knight h4 is a really nice move but here
was the critical moment
oh our opponent played a really good
move knight c6 that's also fine
d e
knight d7 knight f bishop g5 and yeah
here
after f6 knight f5 was the key moment
where black simply has to castle
and this just shows you that
greed is like
you know you're up a piece you know that
you're winning by castling just castle
even if you don't see
the refutation after f takes g5 it's not
worth it
right all you should see is that this
gets complicated and your king is still
weak
i mean look at the evil change that's
crazy
so castles and white can resign for all
intents and purposes
i mean we would have to take the knight
and drop the bishop back and hope for a
miracle but there's no comp for the
extra piece
um
so my mistake was was was making an
assumption i've been doing this with my
highest rated students recently we were
basically going through
and cataloging a lot of positions where
it's hard to find the right move because
we make a certain assumption
about the position and i i divided this
into two categories
uh position based assumptions sorry move
based assumptions and board-based
assumptions
um and move-based assumptions are
situations where you don't consider a
move because it falls out of your field
of vision for example your opponent
attacks your queen and rather than
moving your queen the correct move is to
create some stronger threat but you
don't consider it because you only look
at moving the queen
um
board-based assumptions are
assumptions you make about a certain
position based on certain cues about the
position so i made a board-based
assumption in considering the pawn on e7
means that white doesn't have an attack
which is untrue
another
type of based assumption is
thinking that everything is going on on
the king's side
so therefore the correct move also has
to happen on the king's side whereas in
fact the correct move happens on the
queen side and it's very very hard to
consider those kinds of moves
so you might say do you have an example
of this i don't understand what you're
talking about i do
um here's a great example of another
board based assumption
and this is the game pilnik against
karis
um which uh keras is somebody that most
people should be familiar with one of
the strongest pla the strongest player
ever to come from estonia
uh top 10 in the world
uh you know throughout the 50s and 60s
amazing attacking player
yeah there's a good book on his games
keras rhodes at the top so this position
occurs on the board
it's black to play
um
so
what what what like do you see when you
look at this position
for for a while well
you know you you probably all of our
eyes probably gravitate toward the same
things
uh which is of course the queen on h3
you might also see the knight on e5 and
the fact that knight f3 check is almost
mating on the spot
but of course it's not because if bishop
takes f3
um
e takes f3 queen takes f3 that doesn't
seem to lead anywhere
so we probably all see that then you
might say what about knight g4
but you'll once again see that there's a
bishop there and the bishop can capture
the knight
um and you might also be tempted by the
move f4 which a lot of my students
propose in this position just because it
kind of may look like the right move but
i love to give positions like this where
there's a tempting move and it's just
wrong because what does this actually
accomplish after queen takes f4
nothing right i mean black's not getting
anywhere so you might then say well what
if we try to get rid of the bishop but
you can't get rid of the bishop the
bishop's very safe behind a wall of
pawns
so what the heck did caris do in this
position and this is where avoiding
board-based assumptions is important
in your mind in your mind's eye it's so
easy to like draw the square and only
think within the square
but
look at the other side of the board
because you can do something on the
queen side that connects to the king
side you have long range pieces
and some of you are seeing it the move
is before brilliant move
with the idea of dislodging not the
bishop but the knight with bishop b5 and
involving black's bishop in the attack
now
if white plays bishop e2 then you can
already play knight f3
and bishop f3 there's queen takes f1
mate
so white has to play knight d2
but
second principle just because an idea
doesn't work in one position doesn't
mean it doesn't work in another you have
to keep testing the most tempting moves
again and again because something
without even you realizing might have
changed to make it possible and so now
knight f3 check brilliantly works
now you might say i don't understand it
it loses a rook well no he takes f3
first all the work is defended second of
all there's a queen g2 made threat and
if queen takes f3 there is check mate on
e1
and the same thing happens by the way
after knight takes it three that doesn't
matter rookie one or queen g2 is made
so what changed is that the knight moved
away from f1 and now there's a bishop on
b5
now pill nick who a very strong
argentinian player correctly played c4
and the game goes on keras token c4 and
return to e5 but what
uh black is winning bishop b5 is still
coming knight f3 check is now a threat
and karis went on to win
pretty quickly
karis went on to win pretty quickly
um if you guys want i have another
example of a board based assumption
so i was playing a tournament in holland
in 2012
and i was i was hunting for gm norms at
that point
and i played this brilliant game against
the gm
pretty low rated gm but still
and after 29 moves we reached the
following position great preparation
i mean it was a dynamite game
so it's white to play in this position
all right
i'm playing wide i've sacrificed the
knight as you can see black has three
minors white is two
but just look at the attack on the black
king
i mean
boom boom boom boom
everything is in the attack and i i knew
that i had checkmate here somewhere
now
the move is not a queen side move by the
way that that this is not the kind of
assumption
but
this i made a a very damaging assumption
that that stems from the fact from stems
from the way that my attack is organized
so i was like okay well
where is the mate going to come from
and yeah and i thought well the mate's
definitely going to be delivered on h7
so what i need to do sorry what i need
to do is i need to cut off the rook from
the knight and i oh what if i play
bishop g7 this is checkmate well it's
not checkmate yet because of rook takes
g7
but um
how can you prepare bishop g7 check
yeah you can play simply e takes f6
which i played very quickly thinking
that there is simply no way to stop
bishop g7 check and then that's going to
be mate
but amazingly
amazingly
black has not only a defense but after
this move black is winning
complete swindle
not rook takes f6 that does not stop
bishop g7 because that's a check
and that's it
does anybody see it
very good monk got it queen takes b2 out
of nowhere
a move on the queen side to defend
against something on the king's side
again i made the assumption of not
looking at the queen side
at all
because i just didn't see how it would
be connected
but after bishop g7 check x-ray defense
the queen defends g7 through the x-ray
through the control through the f6 pawn
rook takes g7
and like magic the queen appears on g7
there's no more attack
you have to trade the queens because now
the rook is hanging with checkmate
and
to add insult to injury the move g4
which may seem to win one of the knights
fails the knight g5
attacking and trapping the rook so black
has two pieces for a rock black is a
winning end game
and i lost and had i won this game i
would have very likely gotten a norm
this was round five i was having a great
tournament
so there is checkmate here instead of
this there is checkmate
but to find this checkmate you have to
dissociate yourself from the idea that
the maid has to happen on h7 or on the h
file at all
notice the g8 square this square is also
accessible if the queen can get there
that's mate
well what needs to happen for the queen
to get there well you probably need a
rook on g3 right
so should we play rook g3 well no
because of knight takes g3 and
you haven't gained anything by
distracting the knight so can we get rid
of the knight
and
now you should see this
straightforwardly it's bishop takes f5
ef is forced because the bishop g7 was a
threat there rook g3
and the game is over
queen g8 is unstopped basically
unstoppable if black moves the bishop
then there's queen takes rook
if black plays knight g5 and this is
quite beautiful you play bishop takes g5
fg and now you switch back to the h file
to give the mate
now you switch back to the h file to
give the mate which is
awesome
i can give you an it one more since
we're on the topic of like assumptions
and we we can turn the speedrun game
into sort of a lecture
um i'm going to give you one more
example before we we end
which is an example of a move-based
assumption
which is an example and a crazy example
that i've given only my like highest
rated students so you'll get a taste of
like you'll get a taste of what a lesson
with a 2350 looks like you know like
i've got a lot of questions about like
what do you what do you give
like master level students what kinds of
problems do they solve
what is a like a master level exercise
actually look like
well i've got a good example for you
so one thing i'll say about like
lessons with masters
is that
when i give exercises when i solve
exercises it's not about beauty anymore
or
the exercise shouldn't make you want to
say oh this is cool although it kind of
does
um like hopefully that that's something
that happens but it's not really about
giving the most beautiful position it's
about
giving a position that you know really
helps exercise a certain theme you're no
longer that interested in you know
looking at something because it's
beautiful because there's a queen sack
you're more interested in targeted
improvement
so this is a game between two gms not
2022 that's a mistake it's like 1970s
um
in like 1970-something
planets was a
very interesting player grandmaster
langevig i think is still alive
yeah he's 85 he's an im
um
and it's white to play so why the
sacrifice to peace
and at first sight it may seem like
white has absolutely zero compensation
zero
right i mean white does have a pawn for
the piece
or two pawns rather but black's got the
queen side attack going the rook is
attacked
this is garbage right this looks like
garbage for white
a rook takes d6 was proposed but what
does that actually do thank you carly
for the raid
thank you so much i appreciate it we're
finishing up a stream here
this doesn't do anything black's king is
safe knight e4 for instance
and white can resign
because you can't even take the knight
because of this
but snot rook takes d6
so what the heck does white even do here
how do you even try to generate
compensation well there is a very strong
move here
um
and that move you have to follow the
rules right consider the captures
and checks first there are no checks
now some of you guys are thinking about
f5 but this is way too
this is like trying to kill a dinosaur
by
you know stabbing it with a pencil
it's like okay bishop takes d5
um queen takes d5
okay first of all you're not attacking
the rook on a8
because
the queen is defending it i understand
that you want to play g6 but what if
black just plays g6
um
f6 bishop f8 what i mean where are you
going from here you're down to full rook
remember
just like having a tiny advantage such
as a passport on f6 that doesn't nearly
compensate for the rook but fischer seb
is suggesting something interesting
which is
what if we take the knight on c5 of the
bishop
well that's kind of a weird move first
of all what happens after d takes e5
well loose pieces drop off and also
notice the contact between the rook and
the bishop the move rook d7 forks the
two bishops because one of them is
attacked twice and only defended once
the other is not defended at all
okay
now that's we're getting somewhere but
but there's a problem
and the problem is
in this position what can black do other
than dc5
well black can take the rook black can
take the row
and as you're calculating this remember
that a master player would do this in
their head
and
here
the the crazy line is you might spot a
further idea with white how does white
even avoid being a rook down
well there is a way to avoid being a
rook down and white went for this line
planets the grand master
missed the correct move and went for
that line which is what
no it's not rook takes c7
it's not rook takes c7 because of rook
takes c7 and again i think a lot of you
are forgetting that the rook on aid is
protected by the queen
it's not knight takes d5 because that
allows the queen trait to happen and
then you're down on exchange in an end
game the only feasible move is queen
takes d5
and planets had calculated that after d
takes c5
you you can't take on c5 of the queen
because you lose the rook on a8 with
check
white plays rook takes c7 and guess what
this looks pretty decent for white
white's got a pawn for the exchange
white's got huge pressure on the rook
and after rook 88 your move f5 is very
interesting and it's a complicated game
so this was sort of the first assumption
that planets made which is
a move based assumption often manifests
itself as just not realizing that the
opponent has alternatives
not realizing that the opponent has
alternatives and in this position it
sure looks like black has to take the
bishop
how what else could black possibly do
and yet there is a brilliant desperado
move here that black played and that
totally changes the landscape of the
position what is it it's a desperado
move that's a big hint
yeah two pawns for the exchange sorry
sasha
rook f4 is illegal
bishop takes pawn g5 yes
boom
okay
white has to take
black plays dc
and if you go down the same line
here white has only one pawn for the
exchange and most importantly the f file
is wide open and white doesn't have the
idea of going f5 g6
white doesn't have the idea of going f5
g6 and so
black is actually much much better here
and white ended up losing the game
if i'm not mistaken
um
why didn't yeah 1974 by the way white
lost the game very very quickly because
what happens here
is that black is queen a6
and white's position collapses the queen
is infiltrating to f1 and your busted
planets did his best
king h8 simply moving the king away from
the pin
and black hunted down the white king
in the end
it's actually a pretty cool finale
yeah and white resigned here because
he's checkmated and he's down a million
pieces
so black won the game
but
in addition to assuming that bishop
takes g5
does not exist because black has to take
on c5 we made an assumption on our end
and this assumption is far more powerful
what assumption do we make in this
position
we assume that because we're down a rook
the correct move has to be a capture
right we only considered captures
because
how can you be down a rook and make a
move here that's not a capture right
that just doesn't compute
and yet there is an absolutely
incredible resource that not only uh
preserves a playable position but gives
white a pretty big advantage
and it's an incredible move
and i'll give you guys a chance to spot
it
but it's genuinely very very hard
some of you got it very very close
it's not bishop b4 because then there's
simply queen takes before
but the right idea the wrong execute
before there is on pasan you're
forgetting that you're forgetting about
on passant
we already looked at knight takes d5
it's bishop to b6 i think one a couple
of you got it
bishop to b6
now what the hell is the idea well black
has to take
now you play knight takes d5 forking the
queen and the bishop but there's an
obvious flaw or so it seems in this
concept right black can just freaking go
back to b7 and the game is over
but it's not over it's not over because
now you play knight takes c7 check
and after rookie seven you take on e7
and you win the rook in the corner queen
d5 with a winning queen end game
and it's crucial that you take with
check otherwise black would have
checkmate on e1
so if there was a pawn black one was on
h6 instead king h7 would win here
so obviously black does not have to
recapture black and move the king to the
side
but
remember that here white has preserved
two pawns for the exchange
and after the knight returns to d5 white
has complete domination in the center
given this incredibly strong knight and
white is actually better
so
bishop b6 was missed by white completely
i'm sure
and is missed by the vast majority of
people who solve this because you see
bishop c5 if you're let's say 2200
you're going to calculate
this line pretty quickly and you're
going to think in most cases that this
is the solution for white
and you're going to miss bishop takes g5
but if you're like an im or a gm
then you're probably going to see bishop
takes g5 and it's likely that you'll
miss bishop b6
but exercises are supposed to be much
more challenging than
you know
than real game scenarios because you
have the advantage of knowing that it's
an exercise
i don't think there's a book on this i
mean this is something i definitely want
to write about at some point and this
was the zen behind my third book which
is i want to cover seven or eight
concepts that are very poorly covered in
chess literature and this would be one
of them
like nobody really talks about
assumptions like
that's a topic that just doesn't seem
well discussed
sorry bishop the correct eval is equal
but black has to be accurate so you can
see with the engine
um
one moment
and i know this was like super super
hard but hopefully you enjoyed like
watching
the process unfold
you can see that the evil is equal
but after bishop c5 bishop d5 queen d5
bishop takes g5 and black is clearly
better slash winning
what's up hess
um
danya book
yeah it'll be my first so bishop b6
queen b6 i mean basically queen b7 is
the human move and white is better here
white is a little bit better knight e7
queen h8 and actually why i can't even
take d6
well i can even take d6 and i think
practically speaking white's got great
chances here
um but yeah according to the computer
it's essentially equal
in in your games tens of such examples
yeah but i i mean i like examples from
other games too
anyways to return to our game
and complete that
so yeah uh we were losing and uh f takes
g5 greed
green never pays off in chess okay
sometimes it does but not in this case
king of fate and now the the key move
was queen b3 missed by our opponent not
queen f3 check again assumptions
a lot of people would play this move
automatically
but the check can be intercepted
and uh it's very important not to lose
sight of the big picture because i think
this is a very common path you say oh i
win the night but you're down two nights
you're down two pieces to begin with so
as i said during the game
don't think of things in absolute terms
like oh winning a piece is good
therefore i'm gonna do it when you're
down two pieces or you've sacrificed a
queen
you gotta go for the for the big prize
you can't just like
you know chip away at the material
disadvantage so queen b3 is the move and
queen f7 is cannot be defended against
according to the engine the move g3 was
the strongest which is crazy
threatening queen f3 check and preparing
to take this knight after you take the
queen black's queen cannot get anywhere
i think if i wrote the book
it would sell really really well i mean
because you guys are awesome and would
probably buy it
anyways the game ends because even
though black has three pieces for the
queen and that technically is enough
material look at how discombobulated
black hole position is the pin along the
e file is terrible
our opponent could have been more
resilient but
okay you can't really
you can you can
i mean
you can't really blame them alright guys
not the soundest game but i think it led
to a really interesting discussion so
i'm not unhappy
on that note i'm gonna head to bed
hope you enjoyed the speedrun game see
you guys later thank you for hanging out
thank you for the support see you
tomorrow
[Music]
you